Now, I've discovered something about the
US markets that has become incredibly
predictable and repeatable. It allows me
to trade only 60 to 90 minutes in the
morning to consistently find profitable
trades every day before going to my
full-time job teaching people how to
trade. And this hasn't just worked for
me, it's worked for a ton of other
people and has stopped them from jumping
from strategy to strategy, ending their
years of struggle with trading. They
finally found something that is
consistent. I've narrowed this discovery
down to a combination of three powerful
market patterns and tricks most people
overlook. Once you know all three, you
will never look at the market the same
way again. You will consistently be able
to spot profitable opportunities in the
market. And I'll also show you a trade I
took this morning that has a bonus
insight that will bring everything
together for you. Now, I used to be like
Mark. Mark has always consistently lost
money trading because he has no
direction. And here's why. He doesn't
look for a specific pattern to trade. He
doesn't patiently wait for his trading
plan to happen. Instead, he is
constantly trying to capture every move
in the market, not wanting to miss out
on any potential money he could make.
Mark's approach is chaotic. He jumps
into trades just because the market is
moving, assuming he could catch a quick
one, but it never works. His trades are
always rushed based on guesses rather
than waiting for a clear plan that he
can consistently execute over time.
Instead, he consistently loses money
over time. Now, that was me for years.
But then I started to trade more like
Alex. Alex knows something most traders
don't. To be consistently profitable, he
knew to wait for specific patterns and
other tricks he observed about the
market because patiently waiting for a
specific strategy every day and those
factors to show up is how you become
profitable. And if those patterns don't
show up, he simply takes no trades and
moves on to the next day. He's not
frantically trying to capture every move
in the market. As aspiring traders, we
all want to be as close to Alex as
possible. So, let me walk you through
the three secrets someone like Alex
waits for every day to show up in the
market before taking a profitable trade.
Now, let's jump into the first secret,
which is extremely crucial to understand
where the opportunities in the market
are. But if you don't couple it with the
second secret we're going to go over, it
won't matter. Now, when the market has a
massive move in one direction, most
traders get too caught up like Mark
thinking how they can get in and catch
that momentum in the same direction. But
this usually baits them into a losing
trade because the market is actually
overextended when it gets to spots like
this and it needs to snap back. The
market likes to move in healthy,
methodical movements. Every move up is
countered with a healthy pullback. This
is how a stable trend operates. An
unstable trend is when it shoots in one
direction extremely quickly. When this
happens, it's likely to fail because of
the rubber band effect. To become
healthy again, it needs to have a
pullback. And because it's so
overextended, that pullback can be very
extreme. Using this knowledge, we can
spot potential reversal opportunities
when the market gets overextended. Now,
if you still need a trading platform to
look for these moves in the market, I've
used Ninja Trader for over 5 years for
all my trades, and I found it to be the
best platform out there. You can check
it out via this QR code or the link in
the description. Now, this second secret
is even more crucial because it times
your entries with big players and market
moves. And secret three will show you
the final piece that ties it all
together, giving you the ability to
consistently find high reward
opportunities while avoiding false
signals that just losing these first two
tricks can give you and cause you to
lose money. So, here's the thing. Most
traders don't realize that the market
actually baits them. At 9:30 Eastern
Standard Time, when the US stock market
opens, big players like hedge funds and
institutions come in and push the market
in one direction. It tempts traders like
Mark to jump in thinking they're going
to catch that initial move and, you
know, they FOMO in not wanting to miss
out, but that move often sets them up
for a reversal in the opposite
direction. Just kind of like we talked
about with the rubber band effect. This
baiting effect often repeats and it's
the reason timing is so crucial. This
timing often happens 30 minutes after
the US market opens. It can be slightly
before or after, but that's when you
want to be looking out for it. Now, I've
tracked this pattern over just the last
week, and it's happened three out of the
five days. Knowing this timing lets you
anticipate when these moves are likely
to occur and you can show up to the
market with that in mind and planned
every day. I've also created a free
30inut reversal strategy guide that
shows you more setups and in-depth on
how to use this properly and you can
download it via this QR code or the link
in the description. But there's one
secret that is the most important part,
and it's where everything comes
together. Let me walk you through a real
trade I took this morning in under 60
minutes that made me almost $1,300 to
show you these three secrets in action.
Now, before the market gets to the
timing and the rubber band move, there's
something else I want to see. I open my
charts every morning looking for key
swings in the market. I mark them out
and wait for the market to hit those
zones. These allow me to understand
where the key supply and demand
structures of the market are and where
the market is likely to reverse at. If
the timing of the 30 minutes after the
market open and an extended move happens
into that level, it's highly likely for
a reversal when all three of those line
up. These are the key big picture ideas
I need to see for every trade I take.
But there's one more thing I use to
really confirm getting into a trade.
Otherwise, it's easy to jump in too
early and create losing trades when your
idea still works out. As the market sold
off into this level and started to slow
down at the support zone, I watched it
develop. The old me, Mark, would have
jumped in on the first bounce. It's easy
to get excited when you're seeing a
potential opportunity and you don't want
to miss out on it. But remember, it's
not about catching every bounce. It's
about catching the right one. And the
right one is when the market makes a
bottom and then makes one more attempt
to go lower. From a technical analysis
standpoint, this is starting to show the
downwards movement of the market is
shifting. From there, I'll jump in at
the close of a strong bullish
candlestick and manage to trade from
there. The whole idea of waiting for
this second bounce is that you don't
know that it's going to hold this right
here. There's the potential that it
instead just keeps going down because
well, initially this is some strong
movement here. The trend could continue
lower. Essentially, we want a
confirmation that the trend is ending
versus getting in too early for a
reversal when the trend is going to
continue lower. Now, the last thing if
we go to the actual real recording of
jumping in on this trade is I like to
see a strong candlestick form.
Essentially, this double bottom here.
Now, this is looking at a five-minute
chart. You can enter with this strategy
on a one minute chart or a five-minute
chart. We'll look at both of them. And
on a five-minute chart here, you can see
that it's essentially made a double
bottom and a higher low. And with this
nice reversal candlestick with a little
bit extra confirmation, I decided to
jump in, bet the market was going to go
higher. I put my stop loss essentially
where I'm going to get out of the trade
below the swing of this candlestick
right here with the idea that well if it
breaks below that I think it's likely
that it's going to continue in you know
a stairst step pattern fashion down and
so I'd rather just get out of it at that
point. Now before I show you how I
manage this trade pause and think where
you would exit this trade based on
everything you know about trading and
have learned so far. Think about the
market structure, the trend lines I've
drawn, the support and resistance
levels, and the riskreward that you
would like to go for. So, to show you
how I managed it, first I put a sell
order for 2/3 of my trade. I have nine
contracts. I put a sell order for six of
those at the previous swing high here.
Essentially, my thought was, hey, I
think that's where kind of this rubber
band move has the potential to go. it's
going to snap back to that area. And so
that's a really key way to be using
these rubber band moves for your
trading. And then second, once it kind
of gets going, I'm going to move to
break even. So to just zoom forwards a
little bit here, once it starts to get
up there, I move pretty much the whole
trade to break even. And the thought is
I'm going to get out of most of my trade
at that sell limit, but I'm going to let
you know this is a big picture bottom
I'm looking at. It could keep going
higher. So this is a one minute chart to
show you now. Basically, it's just a
more zoomed in version. If you wanted to
get in on this, if you were trying to
use his strategy on a one minute chart,
essentially what you would be looking
for is, you know, there's this downtrend
that was broken, that rubber band move
essentially at 8:00, which is 30 minutes
after the US market opens. It opens at
7:30 for me. It had kind of that
whipssaw rubber band move around. Really
got going in this direction, and then it
bottomed at 8:00. And I of course waited
for more of that confirmation here of
that double bottom and that higher low
to be put in. And then two clear bullish
candlesticks I think makes a threeline
strike pattern. It's very very powerful
for confirming and jumping in on the
trade. And then from there it's just
kind of letting the thing play out. It
got a little scary there for a minute
with chopping around, but here it spikes
up, knocks me out for twothirds of my
trade at about $1,000. And then from
there, it's managing the rest of the
trade and seeing, okay, is it going to
slow down up here like I initially
thought and I need to pull my stop loss
up a little higher just to, you know,
give it some wiggle room. But again,
think about the riskreward. When you're
managing a trade, you always need to be
keeping riskreward in your mind. You
have your initial riskreward of, hey,
I'm risking, you know, $100 here and I'm
looking to make $200 up here. Well, as
the trade develops and as it's up here,
if I only think it's going to go up
here, but my risk is all the way down
here, you're risking, you know, 10 to
make one at that point. And so, you have
to be moving your stop loss to adjust
for that. So, instead of, okay, I'm
thinking, you know, well, we could go up
here and that could be it, but I think,
you know, there was a potential to keep
at least go up here. Well, I'm going to
move my stop loss to here. And that
keeps the riskreward positive, at least
one one or still one to two. And so
that's what you want to think about when
managing your trade. And as well, you
can see there's kind of a sloppy uptrend
here that I'm thinking about. Uh, and so
that's how I'm kind of managing it going
forwards is keeping that math in mind,
but also looking at the market structure
and seeing what I can get. I like the
spot here to get out if it broke all the
way down because I think it kind of got
overextended there. And from there, it
essentially knocked me out, closing the
total trade up for about $1,300.
Hindsight, maybe I should have waited
for a clear break of this uptrend, but
it ended up being a good spot to get
out. Now, if you found this way of
looking at the market game changing,
make sure to subscribe to the channel so
you can accelerate your journey to
become a consistently profitable trader
even more. Make sure to grab that
30-minute reversal strategy guide that
goes more in depth into this and shows
more examples. And if you don't have a
trading platform, make sure to check out
Ninja Trader. And if you want an even
more in-depth walkthrough of how this
strategy works, check out this video
right here.